VIOLENCERE N ASSIATEITH
ANY O SF PARSAN OR
IDEOGICA VWS.
BUTHEY EERMEING SOANY
PARTSF O NATIONA LE.
Bre ATTNEGENEL
RRICGARLD SAYGIVEIM
SOME PATNCES HONTIES
HI PROCUTISBOUT
NUARY 6T ANDHE CAPIT
RIOTS GETTI FRO THE LEF
WHAT MRICKARLA SHOULDAY
OUTANRY 6.
TIEN IS WEANGHIN WH
GARLD N BAUSEEAS SO
FA FAILEDO IICT TRUMP OR
HIS CROES, H CDIBITY AND
THEREDILITYFHE
DEPARTNT A AT RIS BECSE
HAS N Y DONSTRATE THE
VION AND NER T DENDDECRAC IN ITF
CRIMALLYONSPINGITNS TR
ZEROIAVERHE016LECTNMA.
>> WL, JANUARYTH W AN
TRAGUS AACK ONHEULE O
LAW, AMO OER TNGS.
ATTA, THERE NDS T BEN
HEREE TO TUL OF L.
AND THAT SETIM TES A
RIODF TIME.ITOT ITANT JTICE,
INSTT GPHIC T WAY THAT
ME PEOPL WT.
ARRESTS THEAVEO B DUERTHE HE BEF
OCES FOR THEEOPLHAT WER
ARREED.
THEYID N LE TIRIGHT
OR NOTTRIPD OF THEIGHT
JUECAU TYEHED
TERRLY A ORAGESL
ANTHISS THE W THA T
PRESSENDS TOO.
AN IHI THA SOMIMESOU
SE POLICNS I THI CAS
POLITIL FIGE LIKHE
ATTOEY GERAL TRYINGO SOROFUIETOA
Y H, WE ATILL MING
IS BLOWNHE FIE HE,
AND I TS CAS THINK TT'
AN AIN, TO VING RHTS.GA
>>HATS WOTIN REFM ATHREEDOM T VO
PORTANTO O DOCRA.
NUAR6THASOT AN ILATE
EVT.
IT IS BOND DISSTEFULO
FOR SOM OFUR CLEAGUES T
ND FOISTEDNVOK THE
THEIREGISTION A HAND
WA INTDUCENANUA O
19.
>> Bret:YRON>>ELL,HE THINGHEYANO
DO RIG NOW IS KL THE
FILISTERND THE WILL USE ANY
ARGUME THAST HAND.AN T YEA AGO,R
ARGUNTS TOANTOETID OR
THE FILIBUSR.
NOW TH A SAYG JR.
JOEIDEN WASLEADGOR TIM
ONOVID WL, GLAND WAS
ID, LK, JTECAUSEE HAVERYTH IESTD
LEVED AELATIVEL LITED
INDIMENTGAINST FURE A OR
GURE, THAOESN MNE
AREOT GNG TO IICT THE
AGAI WIT SOMETNG BIGR.
JUSTAIT, PLEAS WE WIL TAKE
CAREF I
IS UND AOT OFRESSE
FR DEMRATS
>>re LESE?
ON THIS.EE WH BHUY
U HAVEOT T B PIENT
YO HE OVE 1,0 HOURS O
VIDEAPE.
YOU HAV 1700 PPLERRTED.
SENTCED READY.N
BUYO HAV A L OF PEOE O
ASSATS.COD B U TO 250 PPLE TT
LL BRRESTEDT THEND
THDAY.
AN ALSO, T ATTNEYENERAL
SAID QUOTE:  ACTIONSAKEN TSFA W.
AS FAR A I NDS TO BE.
CORESSNALEMBEERPS SITTI